>>I'm David Miliband, the Secretary of State
for Foreign Affairs of the
UK.
I want to answer a question about how important
is education to
international development and actually to
building security and
stability around the world.
It surprising, perhaps, for a foreign ministry
that we think that
education is actually at the heart of many
of the security and
development challenges that the world faces.
Education, especially of women -- I've come
today from the London
Conference on Afghanistan yesterday, and a
strong feature of that was
the importance of education as a central offer
to the Afghan people.
Security to deliver education, especially
for girls, is an important
part of the political equation that needs
to be developed in its
neighbor Afghanistan, a country now of 170
million -- its neighbor of
Pakistan, a country of 170 million people.
In light of this, the UK is sponsoring a education
task force with the
Pakistani authorities.
Because with 22,000 madrassas around the country
competing with
Pakistan's state education system, it's absolutely
essential that
education is at the heart of any vision for
the future of Pakistan.
So one of my first jobs in government was
this to the schools.
It's one of the most inspiring and empowering
parts of the political
agenda.
The developed goals insist that universal
primary education should be a
right for all children around the world.
It's a right that sadly lacking and I think
that the more we put
education at the hearts of our future, the
safer we'll be.
Thanks very much.